well a border town mayor is declaring a
state of emergency due to the migrant
surge
and blaming the biden administration for
sending migrants
to his town by bus gila bend arizona is
located about halfway between mexico
and phoenix and has fewer than 2 000
residents
mayor chris riggs joins me now welcome
mayor
thank you so tell me exactly what's
happening they come into your town
on bus and they drop them off where
well rachel what they do is they they
either bring them by bus
uh by van or even by their uh
field trucks and they bring them to one
of our community parks
and we really don't have a lot of parks
but we have one centralized park where
they bring them
and they drop them off there and then
they leave
do you know anything do they does the
federal government tell you anything
about them what their names are do they
have a criminal history
have they had covid tests anything
they'll tell us they haven't had a covet
test because they don't do
do that at the uh facility
but other than that they're giving us
nothing absolutely nothing and we have
asked
repeatedly for documentation on who
these
people are where they're from if they do
have a criminal history
they'll sometimes tell us well they
don't check for in the united states
and that really is not what i'm
concerned about i'm more concerned about
their country of origin
right this is truly outrageous has the
federal government
offered help i mean you're a town of
2000
how is this straining the resources in
your town
they've offered us no help i and uh last
night
i literally had to declare a state of
emergency i did it through my council so
it was very obvious so i wasn't trying
to be political about it
that this is beyond what
we are capable of doing as a community
of about 2 000 people
we just simply can't do it we can't
afford to
continue to receive these people
and then try to get them to places where
they're going to be safe and protected
we literally have nothing here for them
we have no housing we have very limited
uh
food additional food and other resources
so i really don't understand
why we were even selected for these
drops
and you have had no response from the
federal government you've reached out to
the biden administration you've reached
out
to your congressional representative
nothing
i'm getting nothing the only people that
seem to be willing to help are
a few of our state
representatives i've had assistance from
senator cinema i've had assistance from
congressman biggs and i've had
assistance
from arizona representative joel john
other than that those are the only
people that have reached out to my
community
nobody from the biden administration and
i understand
that they are talking to other mayors in
the large cities
uh a good example would be the city of
mesa
um their
really quickly has the crime rate
changed at all since this has happened
yes we've seen an uptick in uh crime
all right well thank you mayor riggs we
really appreciate you joining us on the
show this is a really
um just unbelievable story we wonder
where else it's happening
thank you for sharing this information
with us thank you